are they vegan maybe they're vegan does
it look vegan to you do you think
they're vegan press the notification
bell and help me get all the animals out
of hell
[Music]
hello students welcome to class well
today we're going to be looking at this
video because it says karen throws soup
an employee's face well there's two
reasons i'm interested in this first of
all was the soup vegan you know
inquiring minds want to know i don't
know
and the other thing is who is this karen
person i keep hearing about every time
you hear about somebody who does
something bad apparently her name is
karen but you know what let's see if
that is her actual name now what about
these two guys are these decent guys
are they vegan
oh you gotta be [ __ ] up
you're good
we're coming back let's come back oh my
god let's come back
no you knocked that one out the ballpark
okay let's come back with some heat now
what about these two guys are these
decent guys
are they vegan
[Music]
pass me the keys to my truck who am i
they gave them lock and i and i will
make love to brussels but anything she
want i will give it until she i can't
believe today my friend i'm telling him
not to flee i don't believe he's angry
and i don't believe his grief i don't
believe in susan or karen or the other
girl i breed
okay i'm coming back with fire listen
you went there let's go in our belt
so let's have a look at what's going on
with these two guys let's see what
they're saying let's see if they're
talking about the vegan soup if it's
vegan let's talking see if they're gonna
why they're using this name karen her
name better be karen because otherwise
it's prejudicing against people by that
name i was using that poor person's name
my goodness i have students named karen
and they're like why is everybody always
making fun of us and an
older lady down the street who was
afraid to tell me that her real name was
karen one day when i asked her her name
she goes well i could tell you my real
name where i could use my made up now
which way should we because everybody
makes fun of my name so anyway this is
just wrong let's see if the person who
threw soup in someone's face is really
named karen and let's see if these two
guys are decent okay oh boy okay um you
you 100 do come across as a cameron okay
uh
just off the top of this just the way
the way that we just come across as
non-vegans yes yes yes
but i will say
to all the people who aren't even karen
and are white women y'all got dealt a
shitty hand
not really
it sucks to be you all right
it's been like that people i understand
yeah you know what oops oops everybody
that's named gavin or kyle has a shitty
name you all drink about monster
drinking people you know what i mean
energy drink monster everybody
everybody that was named laquisha at
some point what's delta by hand what
there you go
here's what here's an example if i'm
named tyrone i got a tiny dick or if
there's some asian person out there
named ching chong
i don't know that exists but
hypothetically i know it is if if a
chinese man came to me my name is ching
chong
i'm not gonna lie i know if you got the
[ __ ] here right yeah like like that guy
named [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah
is that real yeah he had to post that on
he's actually vietnamese but all this to
say i can't agree that being said
let's see what's happening see if
they're vegan randomly checking them out
today's video you've worked a lot of
customer service jobs right yes sir
right you haven't the amount of
inception of watching a video of us
reacting video of her reaction yeah it's
a lot of inception you just want to take
a second to acknowledge it because we
know it's gonna be in the comments so
it's weird we're doing it before you're
a loser for doing it if you still do it
so shout out to the losers but you can
always write you can always write first
i did mcdonald's for like two weeks
oh no
mcdonald's the terrible word
yes
but why did he only work there for two
weeks that's what we want to know
maybe he got tired of seeing all the
dead bodies
on the grills maybe that's what happened
which leads me to believe or to wonder
rather what what what do you think is in
these guys stomachs right now
what do you think
okay you're a hundred percent of karen
what's her name yeah i think this person
is unhinged what's her name yeah i don't
know who sent me this link or why you
did but this this [ __ ] is
unhinged you're not a carrot you're a
vegan
on him undoubtedly this person is nuts
actually that person gives vegans of
that name
do you think there's dead bodies in them
right now just picture them right now
what's going what's down here
did they just eat before turning on the
camera
is there a dead chicken in there
maybe a dead pig
a cow
or maybe they're vegan maybe they really
are vegan and maybe they have some nice
lovely tofu in there and maybe a
delicious salad and a big bowl of
healthy chili made with lentils and
chickpeas i don't know let's keep
watching
we're looking for hands
it really wasn't that bad i actually
enjoyed it get free food i used to hook
my [ __ ] up it wasn't that bad we used
to get free food ugh that's not food
it's violence
hold up is this girl a parody like no
no i think she's real yeah there's one
of them like people who live in seattle
or some [ __ ] and have too much time on
their hands they see a hundred and too
much money as well she's a hundred
percent real oh she's real that's fine
she's real not really free food
when you're young it is hold up it is
when you cheat and you lying and you
steal it cheating and stealing cheating
and stealing from mcdonald's
no comment don't even find that's a
pretty good thing you can you consider
what they do filing so why would i pay
for the finance if i could just steal it
don't even front she said don't comment
because she wouldn't be like my [ __ ] at
least you at least come on karen come on
come on karen b
come on karen give me some credit i was
stealing from a [ __ ] monopoly okay
from a huge mega corporation like my
standards that's creating violence
that's good isn't that good that's good
to fight your oppressors come on now by
stealing from the resources that's why
you don't want to comment on that come
on all right that's why she's gonna talk
some [ __ ] she went
don't comment
but on the inside she's like yeah every
mcdonald's person i usually just make
burgers for themselves to go off it's
against policies but unless you have
someone who really watched over managers
were doing everybody was wrong yeah
everybody was stealing from them
it's shock well i'm against stealing but
i don't like mcdonald's
they're a terrible company
my girl you finally got it there you go
hey you get them back hey hey i said you
were on hands you probably got a few
screws still left in there you was able
to connect the dots i see you
i see you vegan teacher i appreciate you
all right shout out to karen i
appreciate you okay yeah do you want
clear skin but you don't want to give up
eating that sausage pause well guess
what you don't have to be vegan thanks
to today's sponsor t shanley i get
compliments on my skin all the time
people be asking what's your skin care
routine how do you get your skin and for
a lot of fellas talking about skin care
is a little bit awkward because either
we're too ashamed to do it or it seems a
little bit too feminine but the truth is
having rough skin or having all these
little dents everywhere isn't something
that you necessarily want especially if
it's things that you can easily avoid
through very very good products i
recommend going through that process and
that's where tiege hanley comes in they
got a great system in place where you
can use their products to achieve your
skin care goals i personally recommend
that you start with the level 1 system
which comes with all the basics a daily
face wash which gets rid of all the dirt
and grime on your face then got a two
times per week exfoliating scrub to get
rid of all the dead skin cells and an am
moisturizer with spf 20 because we all
need to make sure that our skin is
protected from the sun and the cool
thing about th shanley is all their
boxes come with instructions in addition
to amazing skin members of th handling
get tons of benefits like the ability to
pause or cancel at any time as well as
free us shipping and because the handle
is sponsoring today's video if you go to
the link in the description below not
only will you get all the benefits that
i just listed but you'll also get a free
gift
rub out that fake so you can actually
start looking fresh
oh is this the soup throwing episode
[ __ ] video of a customer throwing
soup
what
that's violence
it depends on if the soup is vegan oh
yeah if it's not
yes if it's not vegan it's double
violence yes but if it's vegan it's like
hey you need to try this [ __ ]
by any means necessary you don't want
the vegan food is it your face
[ __ ]
this is activism if it's a vegan soup
[Laughter]
oh my god
what
why
into a restaurant manager's face the
customer ordered a spicy
what
what's
what is that noise
why is she looking at you like his
national geographic
what's going on what is he doing
is he trying to mate with the floor
is that african-american over there
gonna do something she doesn't
understand the floor what are they
standing on what kind of a floor do they
have
why is he upset
a spicy menudo soup it's a popular
mexican soup does it look vegan to you
has tomato and noodles could be i don't
know a lot of mexican foods can be vegan
because they eat a lot of beans and rice
down there and healthy whole foods and
for those of you who are always saying
oh only rich people can be vegan well no
that's not true
a lot of the poorest countries eat whole
foods like lentils and chickpeas and
rice and potatoes and carrots and all of
these wonderful foods that don't involve
any cruelty
that is absolutely true
but also they need the animal products
in most of these countries for export
purposes for agricultural purposes so
it's very common to keep some around
foiler's purposes now i don't know if
using them for that purpose is
considered vegan no it's not
right because it's still exploitive it's
not vegan to use animals to cook no
don't touch i actually don't know i
don't know
you can't use you can't even use honey
okay you can't no
all right i don't know about it so there
you go because you because you're taking
the you're making profits off but but
she is correct like in a lot of poor
countries access to meat is way more
expensive than a lot of other options
because meat is more expensive it's hard
it depends where you are in some places
being vegan being vegan is more
expensive yeah montreal in the winter
things cost a little bit more because
it's not out it's out of the season
it's snow we don't have a season here
you know what i mean so yeah we're going
to pay a little bit
an more yeah ethiopia for example most
folks eat vegan or vegetarian yeah right
the reason being is that access to meat
is not as easy it's more expensive you
eat meat on a special occasion right um
but if i go to certain latin american
countries
that's a bit different meat is there
street food everywhere is just
everywhere right and that's when i said
yeah ma'am you either need to calm down
or leave and or i'm going to be calling
the police i said man i can still help
you get you something i just ask you
don't yell and cuss at me
that's the moment so it was too hot for
you to eat it was too hot for you to eat
to eat let's say that it did [ __ ]
discolor the thing let's say it was too
well it didn't just discolor it it like
melted it away but yeah still it's too
hot to eat why are you throwing it in
her face hot to eat you decide you're
going to chuck it in the face of the
person that did not pour it did not make
it that is trying to help you you're
going to chuck it in the face
terrible know what i'm telling you i'm
working on some [ __ ]
this moment like these [ __ ]
moments like these [ __ ]
[Music]
oh
i'm still trying to oh man there's some
[ __ ] i'm dealing with the [ __ ] you know
okay he's dealing with some [ __ ] look at
his friend's face like he's dealing with
some [ __ ] no no i'm thinking and content
about to make some money
thanks
it's hard it's hard to to when people
are just being so [ __ ] as a matter of
fact yesterday some [ __ ] happened
yesterday some [ __ ] happened i'm driving
i'm driving and there's a lot of cars on
the side of the road on this lane oh my
god
do you think he's going to talk about
seeing a truck full of dead pigs
or or pigs just still alive on their way
to slaughter what's he going to talk
about
bro
no no no no no no no no we're good
we just set it up you know what i said
this [ __ ] might have a few screws
there's one
there's a single screw and it's rattling
it's like keeping the brain in there and
i said about this girl screwed up hey
listen shout out to you ladies i don't
know what's wrong with you i don't know
what kind of gated shelter [ __ ]
community you grew up in
i don't know what's going on i don't
know what video you saw but you need
help as for how i feel about every vegan
no
but do we support vegans undoubtedly i
like vegan spots i go to vegan spots
regularly sometimes i go four weeks with
eating just vegan food you know i'm i'm
cool with it right and i tell people all
the time i take cokes to vegan
restaurants like i'm ethiopian so for us
eating vegan is not that complicated so
we do it all the time so i'm for it
okay but it's folks like you who give
beans the worst rap and make all the
vegan stereotypes and make the whole
diet
uninteresting the whole political
alignment
unappealing all right i hope you rethink
your strategy because you're really bad
at it but otherwise i mean you know yeah
you know i mean this is the best type of
this time [ __ ] like
swallow your seam and be like oh it's
vegan you know i mean like that's that's
that's how she strikes me like
everything surrounds that
everything everything she does surrounds
being vegan like that's her
that's her thing that's her thing that's
her persona and when you hear that it's
like religion yeah it is it's the same
thing it's the same thing it's exactly
right you got women who have maintained
their virginity but take it up the butt
why because that's not haram no yeah
apparently okay so you understand a lot
of this is just it's just it's just
nonsense but i digress you know what
kills me too it's like she mentioned
like you know third world countries they
eat like all whole foods plant-based but
their [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
about animals you could be chopping off
the heads of all the dogs and all the
cats in those places and they won't give
two [ __ ] no they gotta be right they
don't care about your animals they got
bigger problems they don't care
right dogs roam the streets get kicked
they don't give a [ __ ]
hit by cars and [ __ ] so i thought it was
so funny you mentioned it for vegans
like yo none of them are vegans because
it's like what they want okay they don't
care for animals but i never i just want
anything you want to say to her no i got
nothing to say [ __ ]
why couldn't you just say
i was having a hard time because i i
gotta say [ __ ] all right
sometimes you got to say [ __ ]
sometimes you look at a [ __ ] and
you're like this is a [ __ ] right
here yeah listen i'm dealing with some
[ __ ] [ __ ] sounds better too you
know what i think she's a plant
that's not a good thing no i think she's
a plant by the meat industry to turn
people on eating it's possible i swear
to god i watch this video and i wanted a
burger
i thought you thought yeah i want to go
to mcdonald's and not see lebron i
thought you said she's a plant like
she's literally a play i was doing
double on time
yeah yeah yeah but i digress
let us know what you guys think do you
think this is a real person i'm not a
real person let us know in the comments
below i'm not a real person
that's not a real person 100 that's
enough that's not real